tírate
y
yo me acuerdo porque al regresar
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué tal cielo tengo que cargar por
especias
bicicletas
o qué
las preguntas también para sentir más
bondad
[Aplausos]
por qué
también
[Aplausos]
es una solidaridad
tratando
si somos aquí estamos diseñados
la racionalidad
y lo social
es un práctico
[Música]
i
el momento
[Aplausos]
es decir le ha traído
cosas
[Música]
recordándoles
salir
la línea será vivida por sus años
actuales
resulta esperanzador
otra comando
[Aplausos]
[Música]
encontrar bien lo ideal es pregunta
completando 50
pregunta
era una ley y nada
por qué
qué
[Aplausos]
los colores ciclos sociales
en el que las dudas
[Música]
a estas dificultades
pero no siempre
o
[Música]
[Aplausos]
simplemente
el siguiente es parte de la tarea
[Aplausos]
ah
ahora y lo que no
yo
[Aplausos]
la cueva de cosas
[Música]
o no
60 grados y te encontrás con algo más
ahora vamos
imagina y es un primer área
increíble
[Música]
granada una cosa
y posible
pero esto lo vamos a jugar
ah
ahora
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y lo más importante en la vida
será qué significa
con tanta presión
o sea que los objetivos de la realidad
cómo se sentiría que está
[Música]
así
[Aplausos]